qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
votre fils l'a toujours aimé les
voitures
à terme les voitures des gens
m'appellent monsieur lui disais ça
change tout banque de france on charge
peu atone et la différence entre toi et
moi c'est toi tu as un tueur un vrai il
est mecque le sable c'est pour ça qu'il
respecte je vais vous dire un truc en
tony c'est pas l'argent qu'il aime c'est
gagné
tu disparais comme ça pendant trois
jours monsieur mouse côté passé ma vie
est un peu compliqué mais bon là est
devenu très simple
qu'est-ce que je dois pas savoir je
pense que vous voulez ma photo dans les
journaux
tu dis il dit à judith de la coke c'est
pas un mec tu fout quoi
puis vous avez entendu dire des trucs à
la télé sur internet
pourquoi t'as fait ça mais tu es malade
pour moi c'est encore quelque chose pour
me regarde tes conneries je suis par 20
des voix
juste un type comme vous qu'il était
garée là ouais et l'intérieur y avait
grosse livraison convenait changer de la
banque de france ou bien comment
expliquer qu'ils ont du fric je sais pas
c'est pas grand chose à monsieur là moi
j'ai plutôt l'impression que c'est vous
qui savez rien